ils ont levé le chantier le 28 octobre
dernier après 15 mois d'activité le
groupe total a terminé ses interventions
sur la commune de touiller un retour à
la normale pour la ville auquel nous
avons toujours eu des contacts avec
total qui étaient de bons contacts ont
parfois je n'étais pas très satisfait de
certaines choses qui était normale mais
nous en avons toujours discuter le
dossier est clôturée mais le groupe
pétrolier a l'obligation de poursuivre
la surveillance de la zone et de son
infrastructure sous l'oeil attentif des
services de l'état on est dans
l'application ici d'une principaux lueur
payeurs que l'on appelle la
responsabilité environnementale et c'est
d'ailleurs une première en france
l'objectif pour nous est en élite et
tout impact sur l'environnement et tout
impact est bien évidemment sanitaire on
va inscrire dans les plans d'urbanisme
l'existence de cette pollution
fava durée sur du très long terme ça va
permettre de garder en mémoire
l'existence de cet accident
pour rappel le 24 février 2019 une
rupture du pipeline a provoqué une fuite
de pétrole dans un champ et les cours
d'eau alentour
après avoir nettoyé les 900 mètres cubes
d'écoulement de pétrole brut
le pipeline a été réparé les terres
polluées ont été enlevées et remplacées
pour remettre le champ en l'état le
'pipeline' une infrastructure en
fonctionnement depuis 1968
c'est pas qu'il a trop de dégradations
c'est que l'investissement nécessaire
par rapport à
à son état actuel et à par rapport à ce
que des racleurs de gens disent il faut
le mettre en perspective d'autres choses
est ce que on investirait des centaines
de millions d'euros dans ce pipe line
alors que total ait une ambition zéro
carbone très très forte
le groupe total a annoncé le 24
septembre dernier la transformation de
la raffinerie de grandpuits en une
plateforme 0 pétrole ce qui de fait
entraînerait la fin de l'utilisation du
pipeline d'île de france